So I would like to tell
you about friction today.
Friction is a very
mysterious subject,
because it has such simple
rules at the macroscopic scale,
and yet-- as I will
show you and tell you
a little bit about today--
very different rules
at the nanoscopic scale.
So I would like to tell you
about friction at the nano
scale.
So at the macro scale,
there are classic rules that
were discovered very early on.
For macroscopic
objects, it was actually
Leonardo da Vinci who
found the first laws
of so-called "dry" friction.
So this was da Vinci as
early as in the 15th century.
And basically, he discovered
that friction depends
on the force, on the weight
of the object on the surface,
and that there's a
certain coefficient that
depends on the material.
Da Vinci did not
publish his notes.
They were just hidden in his
notebooks for a long time.
And Amontons in the 17th century
rediscovered the very same laws
that da Vinci had found.
And these are two
very simple laws.
The first law is that if
you have an object sliding
on a surface-- so there's a
force that you are pulling
on the object, and there's
the friction force acting
on it in the opposite
direction-- then
Amontons found that
the friction force is
proportional to
the normal force.
So the normal force is
the weight of the object.
So he found that
the friction force
as a function of
normal force is just
the simple interdependence.
So if you make the
object twice as heavy,
the friction force
will be twice as large.
This makes, maybe, sense.
It agrees with our intuition
that maybe an object
twice as heavy should have
a force twice as large.
The second law of friction is
much more surprising-- namely,
that if you have two
objects of the same weight--
so you have the same normal
force-- but very different
areas of contact, then the
friction force is the same.
So if you have a friction
force for this object--
let me call it
friction force one--
and the friction force
of this object-- friction
force two-- then the
friction forces are the same.
One equals friction force two.
So surprisingly,
the friction force
is independent of contact area.
This seems very
counter-intuitive,
because if you think of friction
as some kind of sticking,
some kind of effect where
two surfaces rub together,
then we might naively assume
that the larger the surface,
the larger the friction force.
So one maybe intuition
of why this might not
be the case, or one
possible explanation,
is that surfaces
always have roughness.
And so the actual
contact area between two
surfaces-- so if I really
draw the surface of the object
here-- then the actual contact
area between two surfaces
might not be the observed area
of the macroscopic object.
And so this may be one way to
explain why the friction is
independent of the area,
because it might only
be proportional to the actual
contact area of the system.
We have already
described two of the laws
of macroscopic friction.
There's a third law that was
actually discovered by Coulomb.
And again, this is a little
bit surprising result-- namely,
that for this kind of
friction, the dry friction,
it is independent of the
velocity of the object.
So this is, for
instance, something that
is not true for air resistance.
If you drive a car,
the faster you go,
the more friction there is, the
more air resistance there is.
But if you have two surfaces
sliding on top of each other,
then Coulomb found
that the friction force
is independent of velocity.
Again, this is something
quite counter--
not quite, but somewhat
counter-intuitive.
And as I will show you
a little bit later,
it actually is no
longer true when
you look at the nano scale.
Coulomb was also the first one
to distinguish static friction,
which is the force with
which an object resists
motion for a while.
You make the force larger
and larger, so for a while,
the object will stick.
And then it will start sliding.
So he distinguished static
friction from dynamic friction.
And because we
have this law that
says that the
frictional force is
proportional to
the normal force,
I will remind you of the first
law-- the friction force being
proportional to
the normal force,
like so-- we can define a slope.
So we can write
the friction force
as some slope, mu,
times the normal force.
These are both forces, so
they have the same units,
which means that the so-called
coefficient of friction-- which
could be therefore
static frictional
or for dynamic friction,
for kinetic friction--
this coefficient
is just a number.
And typically, this number
is between 0.3 and 0.6.
This makes a lot of sense.
The friction force is not quite
as strong as the normal force.
So the friction force with
which an object resists motion
is not quite as large
as the normal force
with which it pushes down
on a certain surface.
However, surprisingly,
there are materials where
mu is actually larger than 1.
It's possible, for
instance, for rubber.
Which means that an object
can be harder to pull sideways
than actually-- it can be harder
to pull an object sideways
than to actually lift
it from the surface.
So this is a surprising result.
Now, it turns out that despite
these very simple laws,
our fundamental understanding
of friction is rather limited.
So for instance,
nobody in the world
can predict this
coefficient mu of friction.
Nobody in the world can,
from microscopic or principle
say-- being told what
the two surfaces are,
say plastic or wood-- what
is the friction coefficient.
Can you calculate it for me?
We cannot predict it.
We can only measure it, and then
tabulate it-- make a table--
and say this kind of object
on this kind of surface
has this kind of
coefficient for friction.
So that's one, if you
want, failure of physics.
How is it possible that we can't
describe, and quantitatively
describe, something
as simple as that?
Also, in many
instances, we would
like to change the
coefficient to friction.
Typically, we would
like to reduce friction,
because friction is something
where we dissipate energy.
It is estimated that as much
as 3% of the nation's GDP
is "wasted" on friction.
So friction destroys energy
in the amount of billions
and billions of dollars--
cars driving on streets,
machines working, and so on.
Sometimes friction is,
of course, desirable.
If you want to stop
your car on the road,
you want friction
to actually work.
You wouldn't like to do
away with it completely.
But in many instances, it's
just a source of energy loss.
So if we could even make a
small change in the friction,
this would be not only
important for science,
but it might also be very
important for technology.
So here, I've told
you about friction
of macroscopic objects.
Now people-- chemists,
physicists, other scientists,
engineers-- are able to build
smaller and smaller machines.
And there's tremendous interest
to build nanoscopic machines--
machines that are maybe only a
few molecules or a small number
of molecules or
atoms wide and big.
And there's been
tremendous success.
People have built nano pumps--
tiny pumps-- even a tiny car,
consisting of a relatively
small number of molecules
that can move on the surface
if you inject the electrons.
So as I would like now to tell
you about how bad friction
is at the nano scale.
So let's ask the
following question--
how bad is friction
at the nano scale?
Your general intuition
might be that friction
gets worse at the nano scale,
simply because the bulk--
the volume of an
object-- is what
determines how many
atoms are in it,
whereas friction is
a surface effect.
And because the volume
increases more quickly
with the size of the object
then does the surface,
you might think that
probably, there's
a bigger problem with
friction at the nano scale
than there is for
macroscopic objects.
To illustrate how
bad this really is,
let's consider a tire of a car.
So this tire is rolling
as your car is driving.
And we can try to
estimate what happens
to the wear of this tire.
So let's say that this
tire maybe wears off.
Wear is on the order
of maybe, let's say,
10 millimeters every,
maybe, 50,000 kilometers.
So that means we take off
a number of atomic layers
here every 50,000 kilometers.
Now, how many atomic
layers is 10 millimeter?
If we say that one
atomic layer is
on the order of, let's call
it 1 Angstrom-- which is 10
to the minus 10 meters--
then 10 millimeters
is 10 to the minus 2 meters.
So that is equal--
since one layer
is 10 to minus 10 meters--
that is equal to 10
to the 8 atomic layers.
We can also ask ourself, how
far has the tire been moving?
So if we assume that the
circumference of the tire-- so
this is the radius of the tire.
Let's guess that maybe the
circumference of the tire here,
which is given by 2 pi r,
is on the order of 1 meter.
Then this means that 50,000
kilometers-- or 5 times 10
to the 7 meters, which
is 50,000 kilometers--
is basically 5 times 10
to the 7 revolutions.
So in 50 million revolutions-- 5
times 10 to the 7 revolutions--
we lose 10 to the
8 atomic layers.
So it comes out that we lose
one to two atomic layers
per revolution.
If we had used maybe
a size of an atom
more closely as
two Angstroms, we
would come out at
about one atomic layer.
So this is a remarkable effect.
Even when we drive our car,
each time the tire rolls around,
we leave one atomic
layer on the street.
For a macroscopic object, as
we see, it doesn't matter.
We can drive a very large
macroscopic distance
before we wear off a few
millimeters of the tire.
But if the tire of
the car was itself
only a few atomic
layers big, then you
see we would have
a huge problem.
So this is why people are
interested in understanding,
and maybe manipulating,
friction at the nano scale.
So what does friction at the
nano scale really look like?
And why are people
interested in it
after so many centuries of
first studying friction?
One reason is that now
one can do experiments
at the nano scale.
And the new tool
that has enabled that
is what is called an
atomic force microscope.
What is an atomic
force microscope?
Well, it's essentially
a very, very sharp tip--
atomically sharp tip.
So you have a surface here,
which consists of atoms.
And these are individual atoms.
And you're trying to
study the friction.
And now what you do is, you
bring an object here shaped
in the form of the tip,
which also consists of atoms.
And the object is so
sharp that you have,
ideally, just one atom
near the surface-- one
or more atoms near the surface.
So this is what an atomic
force microscope is.
You can pull on this
with some force.
And then you can try to measure
the force of resistance--
the friction force that
is due to the interaction
between the atom near
the surface and the atoms
forming the surface.
So we might call
this the substrate.
And this would be
the moving object.
And we can either
study static friction
by pulling the objects, but
not with a force large enough
to move, or maybe we
can apply a larger force
so the object starts moving
at a certain velocity v,
and we can measure friction.
Now this, as simple
as it may seem,
is still too complicated
for physicists.
So we try to make the
model even simpler.
So how do physicists do this?
Well, they say that the surface
still consists of atoms,
but now we're mostly interested
what happens to this tip.
We're going to
say, well, somehow,
what matters is that this
atom is bound to the tip.
So maybe we can model
it in the following way.
We have here the
macroscopic part of the tip.
And then we're going to say
that the surface atom is really
bound in some way to the tip.
And the simplest way that we
can imagine the surface atom
to be bound to the
tip is via some spring
with some specific
spring constant.
So basically, the
one atom that makes
the contact with the
surface is bound via spring
to the rest of a
tip that is moving--
to the rest of
the moving object.
So this is how we view the tip
as physicists, to make a model.
And then how do we view the
surface to make a model?
Well, we say this is really
a periodic arrangement
of the atoms.
So maybe it makes
sense to kind of assume
that the associated
potential is also
periodic at the atomic scale.
So this is the potential
as a function of position.
So basically, we model
friction as spring
plus periodic potential.
This is a very simple model.
And it was first introduced
now about 90 years ago.
So by Prandtl-- by
a German physicist
called Prandtl--
and independently
by another physicist
called Tomlinson.
And this is called the
Prandtl-Tomlinson model.
And they discovered
it, or introduced it,
in 1928 and 1929.
And it turns out that
this very simple model
of a spring and the
periodic potential
captures much of the
essence of nano friction.
So as physicists,
now we have a spring
and the periodic potential.
How do we think about this?
Well, one way is to think
about the energy in the system.
So we can plot the energy
as a function of position.
And now we have our
periodic potential, like so.
And how do we model the spring?
Well, this is going to be
the potential energy, v. How
do we model the spring?
Well, the spring
has a linear force.
The force is proportional
to the displacement,
which means the potential is
quadratic in this placement.
So this is the
potential for spring.
This is what the
spring does, and this
is what the substrate does.
And what we need to do is, we
need to add these two together.
So what that means
qualitatively is
that the total
potential of the system
might look something like this.
So as we now
translate the spring
across the surface
with some velocity,
then you can see
that this addition
between the fixed substrate
potential-- this one is fixed--
and this spring
potential is moving.
You can see that this will lead
to a time-varying potential
for the object.
So let's look now, in a
simulation, what that time
variation might look like.
So what you see here
is a combination
of a spring and the
periodic potential.
And the periodic
potential has been
chosen a slightly
different strength
than I'm showing you here.
It has been chosen
weaker so that instead
of many minima in
this total potential,
there are only two minima.
And what you see
happening in this system
is that, as the
particle is moving,
the spring tries to
pull it across a maximum
of the periodic potential.
At some point, the
atom is released,
and it releases energy
that is taken up
as heat by the substrate.
And then, the object is pulled
towards the next minimum.
The minimum disappears slowly.
The object is released
again, et cetera.
So basically, in this model,
we can understand friction
as the external force
pulling the object
over successive maxima.
So that's nice.
In this model we can understand
why there is heat generated.
There's always heat
generated when the atom loses
this extra energy,
because it is stuck
for a while in a minimum
of the potential, which
is not the absolute
minimum of the potential.
And then the moment
it's released,
it releases kinetic energy
that is converted into heat.
Now we can have a
different situation.
So this was for strong or
moderately strong potential.
So basically, this
was a situation
where there are just two minima
in the potential, like so.
We can make the potential
a little bit weaker.
And in that case, the
curvature of this potential--
of the periodic potential--
the curvature in one direction
might not be enough to
overcome the opposite curvature
of the spring.
So in this case, we can end up
with a potential just slightly
distorted, but we
have only one minimum.
So in the next movie,
I will show you
what happens when we
have just one minimum.
In that case, you can
see that, because there
is no second minimum in
the system, the object--
in this case, the tip--
follows quite smoothly
the minimum of the potential.
And no energy is released.
No heat is released
in the problem.
This model-- this
Prandtl-Tomlinson model--
is interesting.
If in this model, we
plot the friction force
versus the corrugation of
the potential corrugation--
so we'll call this the
corrugation of the potential,
u, which is proportional
to the normal force
for a macroscopic object--
then what we find is,
yes, we find a
linear dependence.
So this is, if you
want, the corrugation
or the normal force.
What we find is a linear
dependence, but only
above a certain critical value.
So the friction force
actually looks like this.
It's 0 until the potential
becomes strong enough.
Basically, you can think of
this curvature becoming larger
than that curvature.
And then, the friction
force sets in.
So this is at the nano scale.
And our simple
macroscopic friction law
would have predicted
something of the same slope
at the macro scale--
with a [INAUDIBLE] offset.
So we can kind of see
that, at the nano scale,
the friction is a little
bit more complicated.
There's a region where there's
no friction whatsoever.
But then it increases linearly
with the normal force.
So you can imagine that if I
go to macroscopic normal loads,
then the difference between
these curves, at least
fractionally, will
be quite small.
The difference between these
curves, at least fractionally,
will be quite small.
And so we can see how the
law of the nano scale,
explained by this very simple
Prandtl-Tomlinson model,
approaches the law
at the macro scale.
So far, I have told you
about something very simple--
namely when the contact
is a single atom.
And even making this very
simple approximation,
we can already understand
why the friction
force is approximately
proportional
to the normal force.
Now in real life, probably
there is more than one atom
touching the surface.
So let's consider a contact
area where several atoms-- maybe
a long chain, maybe just a few
atoms, in the case of nanoscale
probably just a few atoms--
several atoms will be making up
the contact.
So instead of considering
this situation
with one atom on a spring,
which is the single atom case,
now let's consider a situation
where several atoms make up
the contact.
So again, here we
have the substrate
with our periodic potential
that is ultimately coming
from the individual atoms.
But now we will consider
more than one atom making up
the surface.
So in this case, how
do we model the system?
Well, we think that these atoms
are still connected by springs
to the macroscopic object.
But typically, these atoms will
also have forces between them.
So this is my
physicist's model of what
happens when more than one
atom touches the surface.
Now these are only
masses of springs
and some simple
periodic potential,
and yet the situation is quite
complex, and in many ways,
counter-intuitive.
And the first thing that changes
compared to the single atom
is that now I have the
distance between the atoms
as a parameter.
So if I label the period
of the periodic potential
as a, and maybe the period
of my object of the distance
between the atoms
in the object as d,
then I can have
different situations.
So one very simple
case is when d
is equal to a-- when the
two periods are the same--
or in general, when d is
a multiple integer of a,
and n is an integer.
So let's see what
happens in this case.
Very naively, all the atoms
are doing the same thing
relative to the surface.
So you might expect
them, maybe, to move
in exactly the same way.
They will all move together.
And these springs between
them will not stretch.
In this case, I can
forget about the springs
between the atoms
in this simple case
that we'll call commensurate.
Basically, when the
period of the object
matches the period
of the substrate--
the commensurate case--
then the atoms are
at equivalent positions
throughout the substrate
period, the lattice of
the springs between them
will not stretch.
And it's as if
they are not there.
So in the commensurate
case, what
you can see here is,
as the atoms are pulled
across the periodic
potential, because
of this commensurability
condition where d is equal to a
or a multiple integer
of a-- basically,
two periods are
matched-- all the atoms
are doing the same
thing at the same time.
So they get pulled,
pulled, pulled.
They first stick, and then
they all slip at the same time.
And you can imagine-- and
you can kind of see visually
in this case-- that
the friction is
the same as the single atom
friction multiplied simply
by n.
So this is just the
single atom friction
that we have seen
before multiplied
by just the number of atoms
that makes up the contact area.
Now there's a
different case, which
we might call incommensurate,
where d is not equal to a,
and d is not an
integer multiple of a.
So maybe d could be 1.5 a, or
2/3 of a, or some other number.
And what is the most
incommensurate case
that we can imagine?
Well, the most incommensurate
case for d and a
is that the ratio of d and
a is an irrational number.
So an irrational number
would be something
like square root of 2,
or for our purposes,
it turns out that the
most irrational number
in a mathematical sense is
1/2 squared of 5 plus 1.
This is the so-called
Golden Ratio.
The ancient Greeks believed
that it had magical properties.
For instance, when they
built the temples, the two
sides of the temples-- the
two sides of the rectangle--
were related by this
very strange number,
the so-called Golden Ratio.
It is assumed to be
aesthetically very pleasing.
Now mathematically
speaking, the Golden Ratio
is very interesting, because it
is the most irrational number,
in some sense, that
you can devise.
Now we can choose such
an incommensurate ratio
of d over a, and see what
happens in this case.
So you can see here
that, in the case
of an incommensurate ratio,
the behavior of the transport--
the behavior of the
motion of the object--
changes dramatically.
Instead of all the atoms
sticking and slipping together,
like we had in the
commensurate case,
now the atoms move one by one.
Basically, the first atom moves
over the barrier, the spring
stretches, which
facilitates the motion
of the next atom over the
barrier, the next atom,
and so on.
So these atom chains
move like a caterpillar.
They essentially
move one by one.
In technical language, we
call these things kinks.
You can see that they are
periodic compressions.
They are compressions
in the chain
and stretches in the chain.
And so these atoms move
like a caterpillar.
And now an interesting
fact is that in this case,
friction is
dramatically reduced.
And depending on
which regime you are,
the friction can even disappear
altogether at the nano scale.
The reduction was so large
that some people have even
coined this with the
word superlubricity.
Interestingly enough, even
though this is a very simple
system, it's just, if you
want, balls and springs,
this superlubricity was only
discovered in the late 1980s,
even though we know
all the physics
for more than a century.
So you can see just a tiny, tiny
rearrangement of the atoms--
not to be any more
commensurate with the lattice,
but to be
incommensurate in terms
of an irrational number--
can change friction
properties dramatically.
In fact, there was
a French scientist
called Aubry that
first pointed out
that there's a very interesting
transition that happens
in this system of a
periodic potential
and atoms connected with springs
when you choose, as the ratio
between these two length
scales, the Golden Ratio.
And this is called
the Aubry Transition.
So far, we have
considered only, if you
want, the mechanics
of the motion, which
is equivalent to saying that we
have assumed that the system is
at temperature T equal 0.
Basically, the atoms
remains at the minimum.
It doesn't wiggle around
because of temperature,
and we have derived the
friction in this limit.
Now what happens for
finite temperature--
by finite, meaning a temperature
that is larger than 0.
Well, if you think back of
our simple single-atom model
of friction, where maybe
an atom is stuck here
as the potential is moving
with some velocity v,
then in the 0 temperature
limit, this atom
would only be released at the
time when this minimum actually
disappears.
And then it would
have a high energy
and it would
dissipate this energy
to be cooled to
the next minimum.
However, if we have a
finite temperature T--
some temperature
scale T-- that means
that the energy of the atom
in the potential is not 0,
the kinetic energy.
But the atom has a
smeared-out kinetic energy
and potential energy
that is like so.
So what that means is that the
atom can [INAUDIBLE] hop over
the barrier and find the new
minimum, without actually
having to be pulled
over this maximum.
So what we expect is
that temperature effect
might reduce friction.
So people call this
thermolubricity-- the effect
that when you heat
up the surface--
and in many instances, you would
have to substantially heat up
the surface-- then
friction is reduced,
because the atom can find the
new minimum of the potential
without actually having to
be pulled over the barrier.
So let's see in a
small simulation what
that might look like.
What you see here
is now that the atom
has a chance of hopping between
the two minima, back and forth.
And it has a certain
probability to be
found at either one
of the two minima,
which is indicated by the
size of the red circle,
in this case.
So you can see that when
temperature is present,
then the atom can follow
the minimum locally--
the absolute global
minimum-- simply because it
can hop back and forth
between the barrier
without actually
experiencing much friction.
So in particular in the limit
when the temperature is very,
very high, or the
velocity of the atom
is very, very low, then the
atom with hop many times back
and forth between
the two minima.
And the distribution
between the two minima
would be simply given by the
Maxwell-Boltzmann distribution,
which means that the atom
will be predominantly found
in the global minimum.
And they'll just be
following the potential along
and the friction in this
system will be quite small.
So in this case, if we do
a measurement of friction
versus velocity in a
simulator-- that we do,
then this is what the
result might look like,
or what the result
does look like.
We see here different
ranges of friction.
We see a range where
the friction does not
depend on velocity at all.
Friction is 0.
Then there's a range where
the friction increases
with velocity, but only
very weakly logarithmically.
Please notice that this
is a logarithmic scale
for the velocity.
So the velocity here changes
over five orders of magnitude.
So friction increases
with increasing velocity.
Then there's a
range of frictions
actually independent
of velocity,
just like the simple
macroscopic law would predict.
And then it turns out when you
move the atom very, very fast,
then it basically
doesn't have time
to dissipate all the energy.
And friction is reduced
again, effectively,
because the atom is hotter.
So we can see that the simple
macroscopic law of friction
only applies in a region,
which in this experiment
was relatively narrow, of
relatively low temperatures.
So let's summarize what happens
to the loss at the macro scale.
So the first law
at the macro scale
was that the friction
force was proportional
to the normal force.
And we found that at the nano
scale, actually what happens
is a displaced
curve, where there
is no friction in
a certain region,
and then the friction follows
parallel to the macro results.
So this would be the actual
friction at the nano scale.
And we see that it's a
fairly good approximation
to the macroscopic friction,
but with a small offset.
Our second law of
friction was that friction
is independent of surface
area, of contact area--
basically, the idea
that a high object
and a flat object
of the same mass
experience the same friction.
And we see that
at the nano scale,
it's replaced by a much
more complicated law that
depends on the arrangement of
the atoms, or on, if you want,
commensurability.
so we have non-equivalent
arrangements
of the atoms that
can either lead
to large or small friction.
And somehow, the
macroscopic law is some kind
of average over these behaviors,
if we allow for randomness
in the positions
of the surfaces.
And finally, our third law--
that at the macroscopic scale,
friction is independent
of velocity--
we found at the nano scale
that this can be true,
but it is generally true only in
some finite temperature range--
namely, that if you move the
object very, very slowly,
then thermal excitations
allow you to always find
the global minimum, and
friction disappears-- the effect
called thermolubricity.
So one can see that there
are nice connections
between the nano scale
and the macro scale.
But many open questions
remain, in particular,
concerning the
point two, which is
that the friction is
independent of the contact area.
What does the
contact area really
look like for two
macroscopic objects?
And how is it that this
independence on the surface
area-- or at least on the
apparent contact area--
actually arises from the
properties of friction
at the nano scale?